bonsoir à tout on sera tous je suis
marie grand et je suis professeur de
philosophie et je suis à peu près
certaine que vous vous souvenez d'un
cours de philosophie c'est celui de
l'allégorie de la caverne appelez-vous
des hommes sont depuis leur naissance
enchaîner au fond du nid caverne dans
laquelle il ne voit que des ombres
projetées sur des parois par deux
mystérieux personnage qui se trouve
derrière eux et qui semble les manipuler
si comme moi vous avez grandi dans les
années 90 votre prof a peut-être fait le
rapprochement avec matrix pour rendre la
leçon moins arides socrates c'est cette
sorte de néo qui vous sort de la caverne
mais moi je me suis toujours demandé
déjà élèves mais en fait c'est quoi
cette caverne je veux dire de de
quelques averses nous faut-il sortir
aujourd'hui en 2021 par exemple mes
professeurs on touche pour trouver des
réponses et mes élèves aujourd'hui eux
mêmes ne sont pas avares de réponse à
madame le gars devant sa paroisse et le
gars devant sa télé et ceux qui le
manipulent ce sont les médias c'est le
système comme les élèves aiment à dire
certains plus perspicaces pourrait faire
remarquer que cette paroisse et bien
représentent tous nos écrans et que ces
chaînes ce sont les algorithmes dégâts
femme qui captent qui oriente notre
attention
vous voyez la leçon de socrate et
puissante elles traversent facilement le
temps et c'est pour ça qu'elle s'est
inscrite dans notre imaginaire collectif
mais j'ai remarqué qu arriver à ce point
là du court elle peut totalement
déraillé il suffit d'un seul élève qui
vous fait remarquer que lui ce qu'il
voit dans cette caverne ce sont des gens
confiné des gens qui ne sortent plus de
chez eux après 19 heures des gens qui
attendent devant leur paroisse devant
leur écran les comptes rendus du dernier
conseil de défense c'est vrai que madame
là on est un peu dans une caverne
socrates a raison bas les masques
et si la discussion se poursuit vous
reconnaissez cette petite musique qui
prétend vous dévoiler le pot-aux-roses
la lumière la vérité alternative au delà
de la caverne c'est le cran risette de
l'économie mondiale que les acteurs du
digital prépare en secret alors c'est
vrai qu'à arriver là en tant que
professeur vous êtes gênés vous êtes
gêné parce que votre élève exerce son
esprit critique ils interrogent ils
interrogent les silences du discours
scientifique
il interroge les contradictions de la
parole publique et vous ne pouvez pas
vous ne devait même pas le lui reprocher
mais il est vrai qu'il le fait à tort et
à travers et finit par s'enterrer dans
une nouvelle caverne
et bien moi c'est cette nouvelle caverne
qui m'intéresse parce que je crois que
c'est la caverne de 2021 la
première cavernes celle dont nous
parlait socrates nous la connaissons par
coeur nous savons que la réalité n'est
qu'un masque et que derrière les masques
il y a d'autres masques d'une certaine
manière pour nous aucune évidence est
totalement évidente nous pensons même
qu'un
qu'un extrémiste qui envahit le capitole
est peut être un anti fasciste déguisé
d'une certaine manière nous enfants des
lumières nous n'avons plus de cavernes
nous avons compris la leçon de socrate
peut-être que socrate s'intéressait à
des gens plus naïfs que nous mais
justement sommes nous dotant tic d'ici
parce que toute la difficulté c'est que
le doute rouage essentiel de
l'intelligence collective peut être
contrefaits peut être imitée toute la
difficulté c'est que l'esprit critique
peut devenir esprit de contradiction que
le doute méthodique peut devenir soupçon
facile que l'anc est exigeante et
minutieuse de l'historien du
scientifique du philosophe peut devenir
pur paranoïa toute la difficulté c'est
que la méfiance peut devenir une
nouvelle caverne et le grand socrates le
savait déjà
d'ailleurs dans une très belle scène
racontée par platon alors qu'il est dans
sa prison qu'il va boire la ciguë et
mourir qu'il est entouré de ses
disciples il leur donne un dernier
conseil il leur dit je ne voudrais pas
comme l'abeille laisser mon aiguille on
en vous je ne voudrais pas comme
l'abeille laisser mon aiguille on en
vous qu'est ce que ça veut dire
socrates est souvent comparé à un
insecte gênant une mouche un temps ici
une abeille et l'aiguillon dont il parle
c'est justement l'aiguillon du doute et
socrate no17 aiguille on peut finir par
blessé par endormir par anesthésier la
pensée donc en substance socrates nous
dit méfiez vous de votre méfiance ne
soyez pas dupes de votre désir de ne pas
être du vote redouté votre méfiance ont
aussi leur part d'ombré aussi leurs faux
semblants d'ailleurs si on descend dans
cette caverne de la méfiance je crois
qu'on peut distinguer trois ombres
je crois que dans cette caverne de la
méfiance il n'ya pas toujours un
authentique désir de connaître il y as
parfois seulement l'ombre du désir de
connaître
on pourrait penser que le doute est
toujours animé par la curiosité parlant
vit dedans savoir plus mais ce n'est pas
toujours le cas remarquez le petit
plaisir le plaisir malin qui anime celui
qui soupçonne celui qui voit celui qui
s'est fait du moins qui croit avoir et
qui croit savoir ce que les autres ne
voient pas c'est jouissif c'est grison
de renier ainsi au dessus des ombres d
autres eh bien je pense qu à la racine
de la méfiance il y a non seulement un
appétit de savoir mais il ya aussi un
appétit de pouvoir et parfois nous
instrumentalise on le doute la méfiance
pour asseoir ce pouvoir pour conforter
nos positions et nos intérêts c'est ce
qu'a montré le grand historien robert
neale proctor dans ses recherches sur
l'industrie du tabac les grands
cigarettiers ont été confrontés à une
difficulté lorsque la recherche médicale
a montré le lien avéré entre eux le
tabac et le cancer des poumons aussi
ont-ils cherché une manière de de
riposter et qu'ont ils fait et bien
précisément ils ont entretenu le doute
sur les nouvelles découvertes ils ont
suggéré d'aller plus loin dans la
controverse de mener l'enquêté encore
plus loin afin de noyer les causalités
réel dans des causalités alternatives
afin de faire oublier ceux qui avaient
été découverts et formellement avéré
c'est donc que on peut produire
artificiellement un épais nuage de doute
qui alimente n'ont pas la connaissance
mais qui fabrique de l'ignorance
deuxièmement dans cette caverne de la
méfiance je vois une deuxième ombre
je vois l'ombre du désir d'interroger ce
que je veux dire c'est que
derrière nos questions il y as parfois
déjà des réponses
et notre désir d'interroger n'est pas
authentique prenons un exemple
l'exemple de la jalousie la jalousie est
une pathologie de la méfiance le jaloux
crois qu'on le trompe prenons un exemple
célèbre exemple d'othello le personnage
de shakespeare qui craint que sa femme
desdémone lui soit infidèle il va finir
par la tuer alors même que cela est faux
ce qui est intéressant dans l'exemple le
d'othello c'est que son doute son
soupçon est parfaitement circulaire
c'est parce qu'il est jaloux c'est à la
lumière de sa jalousie qu'il est clair
le comportement de desdémone et
transforme le moindre signe en preuve en
indice de ce qu'il craint s'il n'était
pas jaloux il ne serait pas sensibles à
ces signes où il ne les ferai pas parler
dans le sens de sa jalousie de sa
jalousie le le malheur de d'othello
c'est de tous soupçonnés sauf son propre
soupçon est bien il en va parfois de
même pour nous derrière nos incertitudes
apparente il y a des certitudes déjà
bien établie
enfin dans cette caverne de la méfiance
je vois une dernière ombre
je ne vois que l'ombre de socrate vous
le savez la citation est célèbre socrate
disait tout ce que je sais c'est que je
ne sais rien or nous bien souvent nous
savons nous possédons des réponses et
amant étonnamment clerc pour
comprendre notre monde complexe je suis
très surprise par la trajectoire que
prennent bon nombre de nos enquêtes
prenons l'exemple d'un documentaire
comme hold up que fait ce documentaire
pendant près de 22 2 heures il instille
un doute légitime dans l'esprit du
téléspectateur
mais dans sa conclusion il substitue à
cette incertitude première 1 contre
récit étonnamment cohérent tellement
cohérent que pour ma part je ne le
trouve plus crédible
tout se passe comme si
notre conviction que le monde est
totalement
incertain se transformait en certitude
qu'il est totalement lisible et c'est en
cela que nous sommes de mauvais socrates
socrates avait le courage d'aller
jusqu'au bout de son interrogation il
avait le courage de séjourner dans
l'incertitude quand il n'y a pas de
réponse et pourquoi c'est si difficile
c'est si difficile parce que
le non sens et l'une des choses les plus
décevantes pour l'esprit une causalité
manquantes une causalité complexe une
causalité même disproportionnée et une
sont des défaites pour l'intelligence je
prends un exemple tout simple
cette pandémie qui bouleverse nos
sociétés nos économies qui engendre une
crise mondiale il est décevant de se
dire qu'elle vient d'une toute petite
mutation génétique sur la protéine de
tel ou tel virus saisonnier
c'est décevant parce que nous ne
trouvons pas là une cause à la hauteur
de l'effet produit c'est un biais
cognitif très bien étudié qu'on appelle
le biais de proportionnalité nous aimons
trouver une proportion notre esprit m
trouver une proportion entre la cause et
l'effet en se dire que
la princesse lady di est morte dans un
banal accident de voiture alors même
qu'elle était à ce moment là un problème
tout le monde le sait pour la famille
royale et une coïncidence improbable et
notre esprit m tisser des liens plus
solides des liens plus manifestes des
liens - contingent entre les événements
pourquoi parce que nous avons besoin de
rendre le monde cohérent nous avons
besoin de pouvoir raconter ce qui nous
arrive de pouvoir le mettre en récit
notamment dans des épisodes de crise ou
de traumas collectif méfions-nous donc
des soleils factice sur lesquels nous
nous jetons dans la précipitation
animé par ce désir de comprendre
méfions nous de notre méfiance
méfions nous mêmes de ce beau thème que
vous avez choisie pour cette conférence
tedx bas les masques
retirer les masques c'est le geste
essentiel indispensable de l'esprit
critique ce que j'ai voulu vous montrer
dans cette petite intervention c'est que
ce geste demande du met thiais et que
justement le métier c'est de ce dont on
manque parfois aujourd'hui bon nombre de
nos phrases commencent ainsi je ne suis
pas climatologue mais je pense que je ne
suis pas médecin mais je pense que
étrange rêve ou l'aveu premier d'une
incompétence et d'une incertitude là
subitement la place à l'affirmation
d'une conviction nous avons besoin d'un
peu de métier et je pense et je crois
qu'il y a non seulement un art
d'argumenter un art d'étayer un art de
prouver mais où il y a aussi un art de
douter il y à un art d'interroger de se
poser les bonnes questions et nous avons
besoin pour cela d'un peu de métier je
ne veux pas dire que le doute est le
privilège des experts des professionnels
des scientifiques mais je veux dire que
nous aurions tort de ne pas nous
inspirer de leur expérience de leur
démarche et de leurs méthodes nous
aurions tort de penser que nos
intuitions sont plus solides que les
leurs
parce que le doute la méfiance même s'il
nous donne ce petit air intelligent
peuvent devenir une nouvelle caverne